die universität rostock betreibt ein
institut für medienforschung tolle sache
die wollten mal untersuchen wie viele
people of colour wie viele menschen
unterschiedlicher hautfarbe in den
deutschen medien präsent sind also auf
unser mattscheiben auf den
kinoleinwänden das kann man sich ja mal
untersuchen das problem ist ich hab die
studie auch hier dabei hier sehen wir
das mal das problem ist wie diese
wissenschaftler das gemacht haben denn
sie liegen hier also sehr sehr seltsamer
weise zu grunde eine art einteilung von
menschen in man muss es sagen
anfänglichen in rassen wir sehen dass
hier also da würden wir sogar abgehoben
auf die physiognomie der menschen nicht
nur die hautfarbe also da heißt es zum
beispiel dass man menschen aus südasien
angeblich erkennt an bestimmt auf
bestimmte weise gebräunte haut oder
sogar an der form der augen das erinnert
mich wirklich an eine rassenlehre aus
finstersten zeiten und das in
deutschland im jahr
2021 das ist mir nicht vermittelbar wie
man das als wissenschaft wieso hat die
uni das was treibt sie um überhaupt so
eine ja ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das
nennen soll irgendwie auf den markt zu
bringen
na ja mal was gutes unterstellen dass
wir sagen die meinen eigentlich es seien
zb people of colour benachteiligt und
finden nicht in dem maße statt im
fernsehen das ist auch einen da nur der
befunde dieser studie dass das kann so
sein das problem ist eben dass das
verbunden ist eigentlich mit einem mit
einem zutiefst rassistischen ansatz der
hier der hier propagiert wird das ganze
geht zurück eigentlich auf die
sogenannte critical race theorie das
kommt aus den usa das greift auch an
unseren universitäten gerade massiv um
sich das ist ein einen denken dass ich
eigentlich betrachte als eine progressiv
gewandete apartheids lehre im grunde das
sollte hier so keinen platz haben also
sind menschen die sagen sie seien
antirassisten sie denken aber selbst
sehr stark in hautfarben unter diesen
kategorien und sie nicht mehr das
individuum sondern sehen menschen
eigentlich als vertreter ihrer ihrer
ethnie oder so das ist das sollte in
unserer gesellschaftsordnung so nicht
stattfinden
[Musik]